my guest this week is the former U.S
military intelligence analyst Chelsea
Manning when she was 22 she made a
decision that would change the rest of
her life she chose to leak hundreds of
thousands of military reports to
WikiLeaks about the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan in a bid as she would say to
educate the public about what was really
going on
she was then arrested held in a metal
cage and found guilty of theft and
Espionage sentenced for 35 years in
prison President Barack Obama later
commuted that sentence after seven years
served now she's put her account in a
new book and I want to ask her why she
did what she did
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Chelsea money welcome to the program
thank you so much for joining me thank
you you were just 22 in 2010 working for
the US military as an intelligence
analyst when you made a decision that
would change the rest of your life it's
actually sitting in a Bookshop back in
America you decided to leak hundreds of
thousands of U.S military reports about
the wars in both Iraq and Afghanistan to
WikiLeaks why well I mean you know there
was a seek a whole series of events that
occurred before this and as I write in a
book uh I uh you know there's a whole
sequence of events that led up to this I
had spent uh you know several months in
Iraq
um I had uh you know been an
intelligence analyst for uh quite a
quite some time at this point and it
came
to I came to the realization that
um in my role and gradually as I was
doing uh in this position that there was
a vast discrepancy a huge Chasm and a
distance of sort of understanding
between what I what gradually came to to
be the on the ground reality of what I
was seeing on the ground uh in Iraq in
Iraq into a slightly lesser extent in
Afghanistan
um versus what the public was aware of
and yet I wonder if you asked an average
American on the street could they name
something that you revealed
in that file could they could they think
of something that they had learned
before you leaked it do you think that
they could or what should come to mind
that you revealed to the world that they
didn't know before yeah I I
unfortunately uh and you know portions
of the document portions of the book are
redacted because the US government uh
won't allow me to uh disclose that
information but but the nature of what
you're sort of talking about
um you know it's been reported it
included footage which showed U.S
soldiers allegedly targeting civilians
and then what turned out as it's been
reported to be a Reuters photographer
for instance
so so that's what's uh well allegedly I
mean it has that that was that was found
I think that yes sorry but but my point
is you're talking about redaction and
what we're able to say and and how
things were reported as well at the time
but but it it's that sort of
thing that you're TR you were trying to
share with people that that essentially
the military wasn't acting how people
perhaps thought well I think it's
actually more complicated than that and
even using that video as an example
um you know it's less of a black and
white and it's more of a gray it's a
grayscale video in that it shows the
sort of complexities uh that are
involved um it shows you know not just
an attack on a Reuters journalist which
is what you know journalists seem to
care about um but also on you know a a
vehicle with you know of unarmed
civilians uh and then the people on the
ground the soldiers on the ground who
you know when they uncover and reveal
and it's revealed to them like oh there
are you know injured children involved
in this you know it it then you know the
you sort of see the best of you know
young U.S soldiers you know on the
ground to to try to you know seek
medical attention for for for kids so I
think that it's a much more complicated
Affair you know it and that that's the
that that's the whole reality of 21st
century asymmetric Warfare you know in
this time frame is it is messy but
essentially you weren't just trying to
show
um the good you were trying to show the
bad you were trying to show what wasn't
being reported in your view and do you
feel that a better grasp on the truth
was held by the American public through
your leaking I don't know you'll have to
ask them I I feel like uh that was the
goal and the intention but sure the
American public you know has this
information available to them now but uh
you know also so does history so do
other you know points in time uh ahead
of us so you know it said it wasn't
yours to give you were convicted of
Espionage you were convicted of theft
and I I was not look I I had a court
martial and there were charges of
unauthorized disclosure but you know
like the
um you know like it doesn't belong you
know this this kind of information you
can't hold on to this information you're
not going to be able to in the 21st
century that's that's the point I'm
making as you say you can you can ask
the American public how they feel about
that and for some they did you will be
aware of this view you as a traitor I
mean they I don't I don't I don't
encounter that on a daily basis no I
don't no but you will be able you will
be aware that there is that view because
of I mean there's that view there's that
view but it's usually among like people
who are
you know hardly relevant to the 21st
century Society the most of the people
that I that that say these kinds of
things are you know your uh are usually
people in powerful positions or are in
you know you know who are older so I I
generational I think there's a sort of
generational difference between you know
sort of people who are aware of the of
how widespread uh you know having access
to information is in this era of you
know we live in the era of radical
transparency now that's the sense that I
get let's say that there are those who
who agree with what your sort of you
know what you're talking about the
themes and the principles but they still
feel uncomfortable about the Way You
released the information to WikiLeaks
what would you say to them that you know
did you do everything you could do to
try and work within the systems that
existed that were available to you
within the Army within the military yeah
those systems don't exist and you know
it it's look we can we can rehash this
kind of history and obviously I took
responsibility for what happened I made
this decision I you know I I did these
things you know I and I went through a
court martial and I went through this
process so you know like we've we've
gone through this well no it's just
you've written a book about it so I
think it raises the questions again you
say rehashing I'm just trying to hear
from you uh what you think has changed
as a result of it and how you engage
with those who didn't feel comfortable I
think I think the I think I think that
now we live in a very different era so I
think in the 2022 for instance you know
as a you know as a civilian you know at
my laptop computer in 2022 I I look at
um I can look at uh the the Russian
invasion of Ukraine for instance and I
and I see that
um you know now we're so awashed in
information I feel like I have more
access to information about an ongoing
conflict and say uh you know March or
April 2022 then I did as an intelligence
analyst in a classified environment in
2010. do you feel that about the US
military do you feel it's more open now
that you have more access to that sort
of I do I do I do think so I think that
there's been uh I mean you know the the
2010s are a turbulent sort of era for
large institutions that we're
encountering uh wides you know the
widespread access of information for the
first time we saw this you know
obviously in 2010 we saw this in 2013
with the with with the other set set of
leaks that happened in 2013
um uh we see this with cell phone
cameras where you know and and broadband
internet access being more widespread
and available
um with you know cell phone camera
footage of you know police brutality you
know causing controversies now so I
think I think that we do live in an era
in which you know now there's because of
the amount of I mean in fact there's too
much information we're not now in Era
where it's very hard to discern in you
know valuable information information is
validated from from disinformation and
misinformation yeah of course the the
verification of information is uh is a
major battle you talk about what happens
to you and I want to go into that which
you talk about in the book as well but
just on that point of writing this and
putting it in a book who's this book for
who are you hoping to tell your story to
or convince perhaps of of why you did
what you did or what you were hoping to
achieve so I I view this book as a
coming-of-age story for me and I've I've
aimed this book towards a younger
version of myself right you know this is
essentially a book that I wrote with
myself at the age of uh of 15 in mind
right um you know I dedicated this book
to sort of young trans people as well
um who are you know and uh and that
that's that's how I view this is this is
you know I I I'm not much of a fan of
the Thriller novel so I didn't want to
tell that kind of story I wanted to tell
a coming-of-age story because because I
mean it's not even really a memoir this
is about a time period in my life in
which I I am you know very young and I'm
still kind of young no you are yeah I'm
I'm in my mid-30s so I'm I'm just
starting to to get my life together well
and it's quite a coming-of-age story
because of of then as you say taking
responsibility what happens to you your
your transported to Kuwait um and a
metal bar cage for 49 days is part of
your experience
um well you tell me but but I did want
to ask because you do then go on to do
several spells of solitary confinement
but can you describe what that is like
for us
um sure so the
you know solitary confinement is
it's hard to it's kind of hard to
describe and it was actually really hard
to write about because
um
there's not a lot that's happening right
you know it is uh it it you there's a
lot of sensory deprivation
um there is uh a
um sort of focus on uh food on sleep on
um just trying to regulate your own body
and I remember in Kuwait in particular
it's actually very fuzzy and foggy
because of how hot it was
um it was uh you know like in the in in
the the high 30s to to high you know to
to Mid
um uh 40s and uh temperature uh you know
in in Kuwait and I was uh and and was
you know like there were it was dark and
you know like I just it's very hard to
write about this time period you know
for for a number of different reasons
you know because there's not a lot
happening
um and also there's just this hyper
awareness that starts to develop on the
sort of conditions around you and uh and
and dislikes this like sense of self and
the sense of like aware self-awareness
about about yourself I mean I it almost
feels like uh a more animalistic period
you know for for me where you know it's
not like I I'm not even thinking almost
in in words I'm just thinking of just
food and and sleep and uh and trying to
get through the next period of time
um and survival yeah exactly yeah I mean
it I read and you tell me again that you
didn't think you were actually going to
go to prison and then from for for doing
what you did so you go from that to this
which is such an extraordinary uh
contrast I imagine as well
yeah and you know it was uh it was very
unexpected um you know and this is never
this has never happened before so what
would you have so would you have still
leaked Chelsea if you knew you were
going to go to prison you know I I you
know I'm I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
speculate on what I uh on on what what I
would have done if if I had known
something different
um but I I I I look I I can't change
what happened I can't do anything about
you know or or you know I would have
been a different person if I had made
any other decisions you know it would
have required me to sort of have a
different background or for a different
set of circumstances but I think that
I I think that even
um the potentiality of losing my career
and the potentiality of uh being
discharged and of losing my security
clearance and essentially uh being cast
aside uh and cast out of the the
military and essentially barking back at
Starbucks gave me pause you know it was
that that was definitely enough to
um that was definitely enough to to be
you know that was the the I viewed those
you know in terms of like having a
career at this time these were these
were major consequences
and then there were the consequences
which were much more major as you as you
say and and you get a sentence of 35
years uh and going to America you know
then in jail and I also understand you
you're in a position where you try to
take your own life on two occasions
which gives a sense to anyone who's just
perhaps coming to your story about how
difficult this was I have had uh quite a
journey
um and obviously you know there are time
periods in which you you lose hope and
you give up and uh you know but you can
also get past that and uh and I'm
thankful that I'm here and that I have
been able to uh grow and develop and
meet people and have the the friends and
support network and the
um you know the the wonderful people
that I have in my life and uh and and
that I'm able to see my family again it
doesn't end up being 35 years because
Barack Obama commuted right your
sentence President Barack Obama one of
his last acts as president
um why do you think he freed you what's
what's your take on that well I mean he
said what the reason why which is you
know Chelsea served a tough sentence uh
and uh you know it was disproportionate
so you know he's obviously weighed in
wait in here you know it's not it's not
it's not that he views it as that you
know I didn't do anything I didn't do
anything wrong at all right you know in
his mind so uh but you know I took
responsibility I I you know served a
significant period of time in prison
um you know so that that was his
rationale that was the one he stated
people may not realize you did go back
to jail in 2019 to 2020 this is when you
refused to testify before a grand jury
investigating Julian Assange
um well I mean we I want to clarify yeah
please do because the U.S guy because
the US government never acknowledged
that and they actually denied that it
was a targeting a specific individual
okay so we don't know uh I do know that
it I was asked specific questions
regarding the 2010 disclosures so I I my
lawyers obviously speculated that it
might be about a specific individual but
uh but uh from from our perspective it
could have been anybody it was not
limited to a specific individual
and on that point then for what you do
know and what we know well not what we
now know you don't know as well why
didn't you want to do that
so the the grand jury process is uh is a
very uh problematic one in the U.S uh
it's used uh almost exclusively uh
against uh people in in very uh high
profile and political cases
um you know in various instances
throughout history this has been used to
sort of go after people uh whenever
they've you know like double jeopardy is
at play or immunity has already been
conferred or something like that
um and so I I viewed this as a as sort
of the US government getting back at me
for
um for what uh for for the commutation
of of uh in 2017. so what would happen
then okay so that that's that's your
reasoning because some took that I know
that you're saying about the individual
but some people took that or may have
taken that as as your support for Julian
Assange is that right uh I look I don't
I I know that they're the I know that
there was an indictment that was
unsealed during the process and so the
fact that an indictment was unsealed
during that process and I was still
incarcerated uh uh you know for for
something that had already been indicted
leads me to believe that it wasn't for
that so obviously the investigation uh
at that time was for something bigger uh
but do you support Julian Assange I find
it I find it problematic that the US
government is going after you know the
individuals involved in the events of
2010 yes okay I I even touched do you
have a relationship because it was
Wikileaks to to which You released these
documents I I don't I don't I don't I
don't know if I've ever had any direct
contact okay it's just you know we're
speaking and it's a chance on the record
to to say what you want to say about
that well I I find it probably I find a
problem that I I you know like I
obviously you know them going after the
you know all the people involved in the
disclosures I think in in this manner
and in this way as I think as I think
very problematic and I think that as
this unfolds and and as it grows
um you know and and it goes and it gets
and and you know I I don't know how much
for I don't know who else is going to be
uh brought into this I don't know how
much bigger it's going to get but uh you
know I I'm I'm alarmed at this at this
case and and how the U.S government
um is is approaching this that's all I
can say is I mean do you feel it's over
for you or do you still worry about this
is this something that keeps you up at
night I I think it's over for me for me
personally I think that you know uh this
is a chapter that is closed
um you know I've I've said what I've
said I've gone on record you know I uh
you know I have I've taken
responsibility I think that uh I think
that and I'm eager to like get on with
my life I'm eager to you know one of the
reasons I wrote this book was to
essentially you know go on record and to
build and to grow and to and to say look
you know like you know go to the book
you know like here here's my story for
for for for the stuff that happened 12
years ago that uh almost has no bearing
on my daily life yes but but going back
to jail in In 2019 to 2020 must have
been extremely difficult to say the
least
um I imagine no no it wasn't it wasn't a
dark period to have it to be back
without your freedom uh no I I honestly
I'm still I'm so severely
institutionalized that I you know the
idea of going back to jail is
honestly jail is not a scary place to me
it is uh you know like that there's
there's a part there's a there's a
kernel inside of me that sort of views
um you know prison as being uh be being
sort of like just like high school or
just like
um yeah I think so I think that is
fascinating it's a place where I've
spent a significant period of time and
and I find it difficult you know I I
honestly find it more difficult out here
because I've spent so much time in
prison that I I kind of viewed the world
through the lens of prison first because
like I understand sort of how prison and
institutions work I mean obviously
School military prison
um and you know out here is a bit
Messier and I'm still trying to navigate
things and it's it it's kind of tough
well no I just I just find that really
fascinating because
are you what is what you're seen to be
saying but you tell me is is that being
free can be harder be and more
frightening at times especially if
you've oh if that's what you know right
yeah because what I know there's a
familiarity with being in an imprisoned
environment right you know in a cultural
environment like there's a familiarity
with that like I know what tomorrow
brings in that kind of environment I
know how the I I know sort of how how
the the social dynamics work I know you
know it's a very you know it's a very
structured kind of environment and uh
and now here it's Messier do you miss
prison in any way I think that there I I
certainly think that led just like any
other institution that you know somebody
can be stay at for a significant period
of time I think that there is a
nostalgic feeling that comes with with
that it doesn't necessarily mean that
you know uh that that I want that you
know obviously you know prison is not
it's not it's not an ideal place to be
in but yeah I think that there is a that
you know I certainly have uh just like
just like in combat and of being in a
war zone like they're nostalgic feelings
that that come with those kinds of time
time frames and and and the sense and
the sense of support that you that that
I had from you know the the from either
you know the the the in the other
inmates that I had or um you know from
the friends that I built or the the
friend the relationships that I built
well no I was also going to come on to
you know we talked a bit about how some
may feel uh not favorably towards what
you do but it's also been reported that
you received 270
000 letters I did in prison I don't know
yes I mean that's extraordinary can you
tell us a little bit about that sure
um I received so many letters I couldn't
read them all
um I I do remember that the United
States disciplinary works the the prison
that we had I think they had to hire
additional staff in order to go through
it all
um because they they obviously couldn't
hand stuff over to me and uh I did get
and I did keep some of the the negative
pieces I think it got 11 pieces of
negative mail the entire time okay so
you know you're someone who likes your
statistics and uh that's a pretty good
ratio yeah well you know it's I'm a data
scientist
that's what I do and are you still a
data scientist because I also read your
someone's described you recently as a
socialite I see you in Vogue posing and
also as a DJ so you seem to have several
um several roles at the moment yeah I
you know I I I I'm doing all the things
that I that that I didn't that I missed
and that I didn't get to get to do now
that I've written the book which took up
uh quite a chunk of time you know I'm
able to sort of do these things and
obviously the pandemic sort of you know
uh it was it's been a messy few years
um so uh I uh I do a number of different
things uh but um but ultimately I I
would say that currently my job is
essentially to be a security consultant
I work for a um I work for a number of
different uh clients uh one of whom is a
privacy focused uh um company that is
working on a a privacy based project
that I that actually you know is based
on for an idea that I proposed in 2016.
okay so that's that's kind of the day
job and By Night DJ party attendance
whatever whatever's happening yes I uh I
have been known to I have been known to
be a party animal throughout my life
Chelsea Manning thank you very much for
talking to me thank you and thank you so
much for being with us until we meet
again take care and goodbye
[Music]